>> So I'm Sascha Ellers, and I'm the
Director of Clinical Operations. I'm from San Francisco, California.
>> Alright, and what does a director of clinical operations do exactly?
>> So, I work with physicians and researchers to run
clinical trials. I take the ideas that the clinical staff, the,
the physicians have with a protocol, and I work to implement
that protocol. So, I will go out to key opinion leaders,
which are most likely physicians, try to recruit
them to participate in the study. I will
work with data that comes out of the
study, so data that's from the patients that
enroll in the study. do monitoring which is
basically verifying that the data that's recorded for
our study is accurate and matches what the
data looks like in the patient's medical records.
>> I see. and then, you know, all of
the, all of the work that it takes to oversee the study. it's
a regulated environment. So it's regulated by the FDA, or if, if, in
some cases research isn't regulated by the FDA, but it's always regulated by
good clinical practice and international guidelines on
how to take care of patients, so.
>> So you have to actually be informed of a
lot different things to be able to carry this out.
>> Yes.
>> Now for those
people who may be slightly unfamiliar with how a clinical trial works or even
what one is, can you tell us briefly the significance of a clinical trial?
>> Sure. So anytime you want to test
an intervention, be it a drug, a diagnostic
test or even just changes in behavior,
you want to show that there's actually a difference,
you want to run a clinical trial because
that's going to give you the gold standard, to
show you that there is a difference
with your, with your drug or your intervention.
So the, the clinical trial itself is a way to ask your question prospectively,
design your, your experiment in humans, and then implement that study.
>> I see, so this is sort of like
the, okay, prove that it works kind of thing.
>> Exactly.
>> And this process you said itself is regulated by the government?
>> By the FDA, correct.
>> By the FDA. and must you pass a clinical trial
to carry out your test or your diagnostic or whatever you want
to do? Is that part of the requirement of ever selling your product?
>> It, it depends. so, to, to back up, there're, there're three phases
of clinical trial development for a drug.
There's phase one, where you're looking for
your safety. So you've got to prove that you're not going to do undue
harm to people with your drug. And then in phase two, you're further refining
your safety data and you're starting to look at efficacy.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then phase three are your large
efficacy trials where you're treating a lot of patients
with the drug at that point. so that's
kind of the basic methodology. But then within that
context, yeah, there is, it is regulated by the FDA. They do have a say in what
they're going to accept from the phase three
trials as something that they are willing to approve.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so a lot of effort goes into buil,
putting together a study that's going to meet their requirements.
>> It sounds like it takes a lot of time to do this.
>> Yes.
>> so it's sort of a big commitment from anybody interested.
>> Big commitment for companies, a lot of resources go into these trials. And
academic settings a lot of resources will go into these, these studies as well.
>> For the type of clinical operations that you manage, or that you're sort
of the, that you work with, can you give us an idea of the
time frame that you end up working on? Like how long
from start to finish for any given project does it take?
>> no it's a good question. So it takes many, many years to go
from start to finish. So your looking on, order of seven to ten years.
>> Wow!
>> but within one study, a, a, you know
a big phase three study, that can take three years,
five years, sometimes when they're these longitudinal studies, they're,
you know, lifetimes. So they do take a long time.
>> Wow,
so your, your portfolio just keeps going on single project then.
>> yeah. What can you give us an example of
a specific, any kind of specific product, or diagnostic or anything
that you're familiar with or that you've worked on at
some point, that you know, sort of went through this process?
>> Yeah, so, a recent example that's been approved is a drug called
Zelboraf, that looks at a mutation in the melanoma cancer
Called V600E. So it looks at this mutation and says,
if the patient is positive for this mutation, that if
the cancer is positive for this mutation, this would be
a good drug for the patient to try. And if
they don't have the mutation, they're probably not going to
respond to the drug at all. So this is a
great example of using genetics in in a clinical study to
select patients. But you can also use
the genetic information to stratify patients. If
you want to compare patients with the marker to those without. So it would just
be a marker that would be used to look at how you could break
apart those two groups to look at who did better or not, in that case.
>> Right, and you said, so that's an example of
something that sort of went through this process, and has been approved?
>> Yes.
Exactly.
>> In general, for a lot of groups that, you know, bring products
through clinical trials, do you see an increase in the use of genetics to
actually either, you know, bring these products
through or to stratify groups like you
say, or just generally bring more possible
products to market by using genetic information?
>> Absolutely, I think this is really the opportunity. Is part
of the problem with, with clinical studies is that you're confined
to the population that you're testing them in. So sometimes we'll see
a signal when we look at the entire data set. There'll be
a signal in a subset of patients, but you don't really know
why, and you've wasted a lot of money on a negative
trial. One of the opportunities that genetics provides is to help us
get the right patient on the right trial so that it increases
the likelihood that we're going to have a positive outcome for the trial,
and decreases the risk to the patients or subjects
of being exposed to treatments that aren't going to help
them. So I think that that's one of the
most exiting things about the future of, of personalized genetics.
>> Mm-hm.
>> In looking at developing drugs and treatments.
>> So you, in general do you think there's
going to be a big increase in the number
of either individual companies that, you know, are sort
of doing this as well as the need for
people who understand and can carry out these, this kind of job?
>> Yeah, and I think, I think that the, that
the old paradigm of, of the big pharma and having
these very large studies is going to shift towards running smaller
studies in targeted populations of people that have markers that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That could indicate that the drug is going to work for them. So a
lot of that data can come out
in early clinical trials or even pre-clinical trials.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And it's just going to make it a much
more streamlined process to get those treatments out there.
>> So tell us a bit more about your background. How did you get to be a
director of clinical operations. What did you study in
school, what did you do before you got here?
>> Yeah. so I have a bachelor's degree in biology. When I finished school, I
didn't really know what I wanted to do. I feel really lucky that I found
this this world of clinical studies. So I've, I
started out in a CRO, Contract Research Organization. So
these are companies that serve pharma companies by helping
to run the clinical trials. It's outsourced to that group.
>> Mm-hm. And so I I had my first job in, in a company like that, and from
there came into Biotech and Pharma and Diagnostics. And have found it to just be
a lot of fun. I like to solve problems.
Right! So, it's, it's a great place to apply that.
>> Yeah, it sounds like it's, it's a very
fun sort of problem solving or puzzle solving scenario.
>> Exactly.
>> Tell me a bit more about the Methodology
of, of the study, how you set it up.
>> So, in all studies we'll have a protocol. It's the
core of the study, it's the documents written before you even start.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It has information
about the background of the clinical
question that's being asked. eligibility, so what
patients would be appropriate to enroll in
the trail. And then it has information
about things like the, every procedure that's going to happen and all the data
that's going to be captured. and finally,
it has a prospective data analysis plan.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you know, when that data is available, how you're going to analyze it.
>> Okay.
>> All that's
important so that we're being really targeted, and
going after a clinical question that we've really
thought through. So, yes, so once we have
the, the protocol complete, then that has to be
reviewed by an ethics board. So that's an
IRB, an Institutional Review Board, and they make
sure that the research is appropriate. So our
number one is protecting patients. that includes really pro,
not just protecting them from harm in the study, but also protecting
their privacy. So there's all kinds of HIPAA, the Health insurance. Oh gosh
[INAUDIBLE].
Health In, Health Information Portability. Do you know, do you know.
>> Yeah.
>> What HIPPA stands for?
>> Yeah and protection.
>> And protection act, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Act, I think.
>> Yeah, I always get the.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, so so anyway, so there's all kinds of considerations that have
to go into to, to that piece. With making sure that patients are protected.
>> So in general you know let's, let's go
back to sort of one of the examples you mentioned.
>> Yeah.
>> You know for example that there is let's say a genetic marker in, in, in
an individual that says something about how they're
going to deal with this drug or that drug.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Or something like that.
when you go through your selection process
for the clinical trial, is that information,
I mean, how, how private is that information to, to you as you're trying to
direct the clinical trial? Do you know the name of the individual, and you
know exactly what genetic makeup they are
that causes this, and then you, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> You either use or don't use them?
>> Though it's a huge issue that the industry's really struggling with.
we do everything we can to protect patient privacy, so when we are
looking at genetic information, it's de-identified. So,
all of these identifying information is stripped.
>> Okay.
>> But that's challenging, because, what is identifying
information and So, so it's been really an
interesting thing to be part of this evolution
in, in having more genetic information available, and trying
to make sure at the same time that we
protect patient's privacies as, as we go after these questions.
>> Mm-hm. so, yeah, de-identification is kind of at the core of,
of how that would work. And we would as, in a role like
mine, I don't get patient names. There, there's a single de-identification step
that happens, where the patients become
a number. And then a second de-identification
step that happens where, with the genetic information.
>> Mm hm.
>> So, so Pete, we try, work really hard to protect patient confidentiality.
>> What aside from the privacy issue, how is this sort of new
age of personal genetics and sort of the, the advance of, I guess,
whole genome sequencing, whole genome information.
How do you foresee that changing you,
the role that have you to go through in this sort of pre-selection or
selection process in in a clinical trial?
>> So the, the short answer is I don't know. But you can see so much
potential, Right? So there's this spit for science from 23andMe.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So patients are self-selecting based on their, their history to participate
in that trial. And I can see a world where patients would look at their genetic
information and then be able to self-select into clinical trials based on,
you know, the, the markers that they're seeing. We're not there yet,
it's not happening yet, there are lots of ethical questions that have
to be addressed on that road, but, but I think it's really exciting.
>> So it sounds like you really get to,
in, in your job, you really get to sort of
be exposed to a lot of ideas and subjects that
deal with genetics. But you also really get to sort
of I, I guess I like the, the verb wallow, in
the, the ethics, too and really have to be concerned about procedure.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You have to pay attention to detail.
>> You got to sort of know technically what's going on, and,
but you've also got to be able to remember where you are
and what you're doing with regards to, ' kay, this is a
human study and these are all the things we have to go through.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> in general how would you
describe how difficult is this job do you think compared to other jobs, or?
>> It's difficult probably in a different
way then somebody who's actually crunching the data.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We have to think through problems, like sometimes we'll have a
study that it's, it's well designed, it, it could yield great data, but
we just can't find the right subjects that want to join the study.
So then a lot of effort goes into recruitment planning for the study.
I've never worked on two studies that have the
same problems, they're always different, so. And then, you know,
it builds on itself. You learn, okay, we gotta have
recruitment plans in place before we start the study. We've,
we've gotta think through how we're going to ensure
quality data before we start the study. All of these
things that kind of become part of the methodology. But yeah,
every study has its own issues, and the landscape changes.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So it's, it's interesting from that regard.
I don't know if it's harder than any other
[LAUGH]
job.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah.
>> What would you consider as probably your favorite moment
so far in the kind of work you've done? Just
sort of, if you can describe like a, a great
moment or a really positive side of something you've experienced.
Yeah, it's always exciting when you see something you've worked
on that's approved by the FDA. Early in my career,
I worked on a drug called Sutent. I've worked on
a phase one study of Sutent in gastrointestinal stromal tumors.
and so when I saw that it was approved, I, that
was really exciting. I also worked on a drug called Pertuzumab.
>> Mm-hm.
>> that's called Perjeta, and it's approved
for metastatic breast cancer. So that's been exciting,
>> Yeah, wow! That's very impressive!
>> so they're just these little, you know, those
things happen. But of course, those drugs were approved many
years after I was done working on them. But
yeah. So you never know, when you're working on something,
where it's going. And you just deliver your little piece of the puzzle,
and then other people take over. that's
both frustrating, and also kind of cool. But,
because you can see in the end, looking back, oh yeah, this is
how the, the work I did on that, phase one or phase two study.
>> It feels good.
>> Yeah, fit into the big picture. So, yeah.
>> so equally, then.
[COUGH].
Excuse me. What would you consider one of the, I guess,
the hardest, or most frustrating aspects of your job that would be?
>> I've also worked on studies that did not end well.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Where we un-blinded data, and found that patients were being harmed.
>> Oh.
>> Which is never a good thing. But I'll
say in, in that particular case the company and, and,
you know, the ClinOps group I was part of,
did a very nice job of immediately stopping the study.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Notifying all of the physicians of the
problem and doing what we could to make sure
that the patients were no longer exposed to a
treatment that was not treating them, was hurting them.
>> Right you know, I, I seem to remember in the
news, not that long ago, I only have a peripheral knowledge base.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Of certain clinical trials, but I, I do
seem to remember one about statins that was a big.
>> Mm.
>> was a big study and apparently, I correct
me if I'm wrong here but like, if you, if you
know, but I think there was like a, a big benefit
to like people who are at risk for a heart attack
you know, if they were either on or off the Statin.
>>
>> it really decreased their risk significantly
and it became such an ethical impairment. It
became so obvious so early in the clinical trial that this worked in this way.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That they stopped the trial early, and
said.
>> Right. And said, it's unethical.
>> To continue.
>> To not give the statin to everyone in this case.
>> Yeah! That's a great story. it doesn't happen
that often. And, I'm not familiar with that example.
>> Sure, sure.
>> but yeah, that's very cool
>> But what I think, what's nice is, I mean, you
know, when we hear a story like that or others types of
stories, you're sort of a face behind all of that. Right? You
were in the process of planning that clinical op, that clinical trial.
>> Yeah, and somebody in clinical operations
was working very diligently to make sure that
everybody was informed of the decision to stop the
study, and that all of the you know, like I said, this is a very, in some ways,
a very controlled methodology. So we would have
to like, let IRBs know that the study was
stopping, and, and make sure that all the, the
pieces were put in place to wrap it up.
>> So how much of your job would you say is sort of, teamwork?
>> A lot
of it is teamwork. partnering with
physicians and researchers and colleagues doing the
same work I do. I I would work with people in a commercial organization.
>> Mm-hm.
>> of course there's the huge
financial components. You're working with people that
have budget responsibilities. Yeah, there's a lot
of team work that goes into it.
>> Is there anything else you want to talk about related to clinical
operations or anything else that you think would be really interesting
or relevant to, you know, genetics or just the job itself?
>> Yeah, I mean I think the what's interesting right now is the movement
towards personalized health care. I want to see
how this, how personalized genetics fit into that.
so yeah, so I just think it's an interesting time to be in this field.
>> If you, if somebody's watching you right now, and they're super
excited, they're like, wow that sounds like a really cool, kind of job.
>> Mm-hm.
>> What advice would you give them to either learn more, or
[COUGH].
What advice would you give them to learn more, or
to possibly, you know, become a clinical operations director themselves?
>> I think it's, I know it's a tough field to break into, because
lot of people are interested in, in getting into this type of a
field. So, I think it's really getting work experience. there are degrees, there
are Masters degrees, and there are great programs, through, like, a UC Berkeley,
or a UC Santa Cruz, that'll give you a certificate in clinical trial management.
>> Mm-hm. And, and those certificates are great.
People learn all of the methodology behind how
to run the studies, but it really comes down to doing it and working on studies
which happen both in an academic and a
drug company, diagnostic company now, now personalized genetics
companies, so there's so many different places you
could get this experience. So I guess that
the main advice would be not to just focus on drug companies. To look across the
board for other places that are running studies
and, and see if there are opportunities there.
>> Would you recommend anybody who's interested
to try to get work experience before school
experience in this? I think work experience is the foot
in the door that will help to land the job. Yeah.
>> And what kind of work experience exactly?
>> so, there are entry level positions running
clinical trials, they're, it's called a clinical trial associate.
>> Okay.
>> but also background in a, in a physician's practice that
are, where they're running studies is another great way to get exposure
to it. And yeah, I think that, that it's not,
a lot of people focus on getting into a drug company.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, I think that might be the wrong first step to take.
It's definitely something to put on the list of things to do eventually,
but just to break in and get the foot in the door working
in other capacities, it's probably easier to, to get that, land the first job.
>> Yeah, it sounds like
to carry out a job like yours,
they want somebody who's very knowledgeable, and I
mean, you gotta know the ins and the outs. And it sounds like you might
gain that better by, like you say, you know, sort of getting your foot in
the door. Maybe taking a lower level position
on a clinical trial or clinical operations development.
>> Right.
>> Program first.
>> Right. I mean you have to be able, to interview for these bigger
jobs, you have to be able to talk about the mistakes you've made. Right?
>> Mm, sure.
>> And what you learned
from those, which you can't get unless you're actually doing this work, so yeah.
there, there are other angles to get
in than just going through the drug companies.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, thank you so much for joining us,
and you know, wish you the best of luck
>> Thank you,
>> Continuing your clinical operations.
>> Thanks.